other thing I'd also say about Dylan
Mulvaney is that you said that he's
being manipulated right I think that's
what you said yes imagine he's being
misguided by people misguided maybe
maybe not I don't know but but what I do
know is that he is misguiding other
people okay so whatever what got him to
this state I'm not sure exactly but he
is manipulating and misguiding he is now
a proponent of this this thing so he's
not just Dylan Mulvaney he now wants to
turn he wants to recruit other people to
be Dylan Mulvaney okay he wants to do
that with my kids
and anyone else's kids
um that's why he's at the white house uh
Shilling for gender affirming care for
minors which is in other words
mutilating and castrating children so
once you do that you're engaging in
politics you're a public figure you are
now a representative of this idea
that also gives me even more I believe
moral license to be brutally honest with
you